hey little guys my name is eterno and
welcome back to my sleepless blood
series so today we're going to learn all
about how the people applause compiler
works so let's take a step back and
think about this for a minute what is
the big picture here what is a simple
source compiler actually responsible for
so we write our C++ code as text if
that's all it is it's just a text file
and then we need some way to transform
that text into an actual application
that our computer can run in going from
that text form to an actual executable
binary we basically have two main
operations that need to happen one of
them is called compiling and one of them
is called linking in this video we're
just going to talk about compiling I've
actually made another video specifically
covering linking so you might want to
check that out as well the link will be
in the description below so with that
being said the only thing that the C++
compiler actually needs to do is to take
our text files and convert them into an
intermediate format called an object
file those object files can then be
passed onto the linker and the link
could do all of its linking things but
anyway we're talking about compiling
here the compiler actually does several
things when it produces these object
files firstly it needs to pre-process
our code which means that any
preprocessor statements get evaluated
then and there once I've heard is
include processed we move on to more or
less tokenizing and pausing and
basically sorting out this english c++
language into a format that the compiler
can actually understand and reason with
this basically results in something
called an abstract syntax tree being
created which is basically a
representation of our code but as an
abstract syntax tree the compilers job
at the end of the day is to convert all
of our code into either constant data or
instructions once the compiler has
created this abstract syntax tree it can
begin actually generating code now this
code is going to be the actual machine
code that our CPU will execute we also
wind up with various other data such as
a place to store all of our constant
variables and that's essentially all the
compiler does it's not crazy complicated
it of course dogs get very complicated
as your actual code complexity grows but
that is the gist of it that's all that
it does we're going to go ahead and jump
into this and take a look at what each
stage actually does so that you guys can
see how it all works so let's go ok so
here we've got a simple hello world
application
you might remember this from the house
tablecloth Works video that I recently
made we basically just got this main
function which called vlog which is
actually defined inside this log does
typically file and it simply just prints
our message to the screen and we wind up
with a simple application which says
hello world if we pop over into our
output directory to debug here you can
see that it's generated a hello world
exe file and then back in the project
directory in debug its generated a means
or obj and load obj file so what the
compiler has done is as generated object
files for each of our C++ files for each
of our translation units now every CPP
file that our project contains that we
actually tell the compiler hey compile
this CPP file every single one of those
files will result in an object file
these CPP files are things called
translation units essentially you have
to realize that these both love doesn't
care about files files are not something
that exists in C++ for example in Java
your class name has to be tied to your
file name and your folder hierarchy has
to be tied to your package and there's
all this going on because Java expects
certain files to exist in C++ that is
not the case there is no such thing as a
file a file is just a way to feed the
compiler with source code you're
responsible for telling the compiler
what kind of file type this is and how
the compiler should treat that now of
course if you create a file with the
extension CPP the compiler is going to
treat that as a C++ file similarly if I
make a file with the extension dot C or
dot H the compiler is going to treat the
dot C file like a C file and not a
people spot file and it's going to treat
the dot H file like a header file these
are basically just default conventions
that are in place you can override any
of them and that's just how the compiler
will deal with it if you don't tell it
how to deal with it I could go around
making sure no files and telling the
compiler to compile that and that would
be totally fine as long as I tell the
compiler hey this file is a C++ file
please compile it like a C++ file so
just remember files have no meaning ok
remember that important so that being
said every C++ file that we feed into
the compiler and we tell it this is a
C++ file please compile it it will
compile it as a translation unit and a
translation unit will result in an
object file it's actually quite common
to sometimes include CPP files in other
CPP files and create basically one big
CPP file with a lot of
Isles in it if you do something like
that and then you only compile the one
CPP file you're going to basically
result in one translation unit and
that's one object file so that's why
there's that terminology split between
water translation unit is and what does
it BP file actually is because typically
file doesn't necessarily have to equal a
translation unit however if you just
make a project with individual CPP files
and you never include them in each other
then yet every security file will be a
translation unit and every CPP file will
generate an object file now these are
actually pretty big you can see this
one's 30 kilobytes in this one 46
kilobytes the reason to that is because
we're including iOS stream and that has
a lot of self in it so that's why
they're so big and because of that
they're actually pretty complicated so
before we dive in and take a look at
what's actually in the file let's create
something a little bit more simple I'm
going to right click on full file hit
add new item it is going to be a C++
file I'm going to call it math fill
favorite eat and hit add over here I'm
just going to write a very basic
multiply function which multiplies two
numbers together I'm not going to
include any files in here or anything
I'm just going to write a very simple
function it's going to return an integer
it's going to be called multiply it's
going to take two parameters int a and
int B it's then going to create a result
variable which stores the result of a
times B and then we're going to return
that result variable nice and simple
that's it
let's hit control seven to build that
file you can see over here that it's
built it successfully I'm actually going
to just resize littlez to do a little
bit just to make it easier so now you
can see the output window a bit better
if we look back into our output
directory you can see that we've got
this mouse or obj file now and it's four
kilobyte before we take a look at what
exactly is in that object file let's
talk about the first stage of
compilation which I mentioned earlier
pre-processing during the pre-processing
stage the compiler will basically just
go through all of our pre-processing
statements and evaluate them the ones
that we commonly use are include define
F and F def there are also pragma
statements which tell the compiler
exactly what to do but we'll talk about
them in other video so let's take a look
at one of the most common preprocessor
statements that we have hash include how
does that work so hash include' is
actually really simple you basically
specify which file you want to include
and then the preprocessor will open that
file read all of its contents and just
paste it into the file where you bro
your
statement and that's it it's really
really simple and I'm about to prove
that so that's over here I'm just going
to make a header file I'm gonna right
click on the header file to get add new
item is going to be a header file and
I'm going to call it and brace and then
click Add ok we're going to wipe out
whatever was in this file and I'm just
going to type in a closing curly brace
that is it that's our entire file so now
back in master CPP you can see that we
have reasonably written a closing curly
bracket here for our multiply function
let's go ahead and wipe that out if we
compile our file now by hitting ctrl f7
you can see that the compiler complains
about the less brave being unmatched at
the end of the file so instead of fixing
this like a normal person and just
adding in our ending braze let's go
ahead and include our end brace header
file so I'll type in hash includes and
brace and there we go let's hit ctrl f7
to compile that and look it compiles
successfully of course it did because
all the compiler did was open this and
break file copy whatever was in here and
then just paste it into here and that is
it okay header files solved you should
now know exactly how they work and how
you can use them there's actually a way
we can tell the compiler to output a
file which contains the result of all of
these preprocessor evaluations that have
happened if we bring back our include
end brace and then right click on our
hello world project and hit properties
under C C++ and then preprocessor I'm
going to set the pre-processed to a file
to yes make sure that you're editing
your current configuration and platform
so that these settings actually apply
let's hit OK and then we're going to
just hit control f7 to builders again if
we bring up our output directory you'll
see this new dot I file which is our
pre-processed CC plus off code let's
open this in a text editor so that we
can look at it okay so here you can see
what the preprocessor has actually
generated you can see that our source
code had this include end brace and yet
the preprocessor code has just inserted
our end brace that was in that dot H
file that we've included pretty simple
stuff let's add some more preprocessor
statements and
it does so back in our file I'm going to
restore our end brace because I'm
getting tired of looking at that include
I'm then going to come up here and
define something I'm going to define the
word integer to be in now don't ask me
why I would ever do this is just an
example the design proposals a statement
will basically just do a search for this
word and replace it with whatever
follows so let's replace our end here
with the word integer so that we
actually return the integer we can also
do the same here let's head of ctrl f7
and if we look back at our file you can
see what's happened it just looks normal
into result if we were to do something
stupid here like write the word Cherno
and mention ctrl f7
if we go back to our file you can see it
now there's channel multiply and channel
result pretty cool stuff let's play
around with this a little bit more let's
bring back our int we'll get rid of this
define and instead what I'm going to do
is actually just use something called if
the if preprocessor statement can let us
include or exclude code based on a given
condition so over here I'm just going to
write f1 which in other words means true
and then just write an end s at the end
of this function I'll hit ctrl f7 we'll
go back to our preparators file and you
can see that it looks exactly like it
does here without this thing if I go
back here and I switch this off by
writing in 0 visual studio will fade out
our code to show that it's disabled by
here ctrl f7 and take a look at its file
we have no code so it's another great
example of a preprocessor statement all
right one more we'll look at include
let's get rid of our s0 and then I'm
going to write include iostream
the massive massive iostream let's take
control f7 let's look back a bit and
well take a look at this we have in here
50,000 623 lines and there's our
function at the very bottom and then
look this is all that include iostream
has done now of course iostream also
includes other files so it's kind of
like rolling a snowball down a hill you
can now hopefully see why those objects
class was so big because they included
iostream and that is a lot of code
alright great so that's the preprocessor
once that stage has done we can move on
to actually compiling our simple plus
code into
chain code if we go back to our project
here I'm going to get rid of the include
because we don't need it and I'm just
going to hit ctrl f7 you should now see
in our progressive file that we're back
to normal and in fact I'm actually going
to go into hi world hit properties and
then disable that preprocessor to a file
if you actually read what presses to a
file does you'll see that it actually
does not produce an obj file so we need
to disable it so that we can actually
build our project I've said okay and
then we'll hit ctrl f7 to build our 50p
file you'll see that we should now get a
mastered obj file which is actually up
to date so let's take a look at what
actually inside our obj file if we open
this file with the text editor you'll
see that it's binary
which doesn't really help up too much
but part of what is actually inside here
is the machine code that our CPU will
run when we call this multiply function
so because this is just binary and
completely unreadable let's convert it
into a form that might actually be more
readable by our there are several ways
we could do this but I'm just going to
use visual studio I'll right click on
hello world and hit properties under C
C++ and then output file I'm going to
set assembler output to be set to
assembly only listing and then I'm going
to hit OK and we're going to hit ctrl f7
inside our output directory you should
see a math dot ASM file let's go ahead
and open that with a text editor okay so
this is basically a readable result of
what that objects file actually contain
if we go down over here you'll see that
we actually have this function called
multiply and then we have a bunch of
assembly instructions these are the
actual instructions that our CPU will
execute when we were on the function I'm
not going to go into huge detail about
all the dissembler code now I might save
that for another video but if we take a
look over here you'll see that our
multiplication operation actually
happens here basically we load the a
variable into our EAX register and then
we perform an I mul instruction which is
a multiplication instruction on the B
variable and that a variable we're then
storing the result of that in a variable
called result and moving it back into
EAX to return it the reason this kind of
double move happens because I actually
made a variable called result and then
returned it instead of just returning a
times B that's why we get this moving
EAX into result and then moving result
into EAX which is completely redundant
this is another great example of why if
you set your compiler not to optimize
you're going to find out with slow code
because it's doing
extra stuff like this for no reason if I
go back to my code and I actually get
rid of that result variable by just
returning a times B and then compile
this you'll see the assembly looks
slightly different because we're just
doing a mole on B and E ax and then
that's it
the ax is actually going to contain our
return value now all this may look like
a lot of code and that's because we're
actually compiling in debug which
doesn't do any optimization that and
does extra things to make sure that our
code is as diverse as possible and as
easy to debug as possible if we go back
into our project and right click here
hit properties I'm going to go over here
into optimization under the debug
configuration
let's select maximize speed if you try
and compile this now it'll actually give
you an error because you'll see that OH
- and RTC is actually incompatible so
we'll have to go back over here into
code generation and make sure that our
basic runtime checks are set to default
which basically won't perform runtime
checks this is basically just code that
the compiler will insert to help us with
debugging
let's take control of seven and look at
that assembly file again wow that looks
a lot smaller we've basically just got
our variables being loaded into a
register and then the multiplication and
then that's it pretty simple stuff you
should now have a basic idea of what the
compiler actually does when you tell it
to optimize it optimizes this is a
pretty simple example so let's take a
look at something a bit more advanced
we'll take a look at a slightly
different example in which case we don't
actually take anything in here but I
decide to do something like five times -
we'll save that file I'll go into my
properties and make sure that I disable
optimization so let's hit control f7 and
take a look at our file you can see that
what it's done is actually really simple
it's simply moved ten into our EAX
register which is a register that will
actually store our return value in so if
we take a look at our code again it's
basically just simplified our five times
two to be ten because of course has no
need to do something like five times to
two constant values at runtime there's
something called constant folding where
anything that is constant that can be
worked out at compile time is let's make
things more interesting by involving
another function so for example I'm
actually going to write a log function
which is going to log a certain message
of course I don't actually want to make
it log anything because that would mean
I
have to include iostream which will
drastically complicate this so I'm is
going to get it to return that message
that it received over here and multiply
I'm going to call log with the word
multiplier I want to change this back to
be a and B and watertown a times B let's
take control of seven all right so let's
take a look at what our compiler has
generated if we scroll down a bit you'll
see that we've got this log function
which doesn't really do much but this
actually will just return our message
you can see that it's moving our message
pointer into EAX which is our return
register as we've established so this is
the log function if we scroll up a
little bit you'll see the multiply
function and then all we have here is a
call to log so right before we actually
do our multiplication by using the I mul
we actually call this log function now
you might be wondering why this log
function is decorated by what seems like
random characters and at signs this is
actually the function signature
this needs to uniquely define your
function we'll talk more about this in
the linking video but essentially when
we have multiple OBJ's and our functions
are defined in multiple obj it's going
to be linkers job to link all them
together and the way that it's going to
do that is going to look up this
function signature so all you need to
know here is that we're calling this log
function that's what the compiler will
actually do when you call a function it
will generate a call instruction now in
this case it might be a little bit
stupid because you can see that we're
simply calling log we're not even
storing the return value basically this
could be optimized quite a bit if we go
back here and we turn on optimization to
maximize speed and in control of 7
you'll actually see that that just
disappears entirely yep the compiler
just decided that does nothing I'm going
to remove that code but you should
basically now understand the gist of how
the compiler work it will take our
source files and output an object file
which contains machine code and any
other constant data that we've defined
that's basically it and now that we've
got these object files we can link them
into one executable which contains all
of the machine code that we actually
need to run and that's how we make a
program in C++ pretty simple make sure
that you check out my video on how to
link work so that you can see the next
step but apart from that I hope you guys
enjoyed this video hope you learned
something new you should now have a
basic understanding of what the simple
of compiler actually
and that's going to be really important
when it comes to debugging and also when
we get into more advanced topics in the
future make sure you follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and if you really
like this you can support me on patreon
I'll see you guys next time goodbye
warm